وصف المتحدث باسمي وزاره الصحه في قطاع
غزه الدكتور اشرف القدره الاوضاع الصحيه
في منطقه خان يونس بالكارثي وقال ان كل
المنظومه الصحيه في خطر مع عجز الطواقم
الطبيه عن تقديم الخدمات والاعداد الكبيره
من المصابين ومنع الاحتلال طواقم الاسعاف
من الوصول الى
الجرحى الواقع الصحي في منطقه خانيونس
بالذات وعلى وجه التحديد كارثي للغايه حيث
ان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يمنع تحرك سيارات
الاسعاف للوصول الى الاماكن المستهدفه في
غرب مدينه خانيونس وبالتالي هناك عشرات
الشهداء والجرحى ملقون على الارض وفي
الطرقات ولا تستطيع الطواقم الطبيه
وسيارات الاسعاف الوصول اليهم اضافه الى
ان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يستهدف بشكل مركز
محيط مجمع ناصر الطبي ويقوم ايضا بتحييد
هذا المجمع وعدم قدره الطواقم الطبيه من
التحرك في داخل هذا المجمع والوصول الى
قسم الطوارئ والاقسام الاخرى وبالتالي في
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يمعن في استهداف هذا
المجمع الذي يعتبر الوحيد في تلك المنطقه
الحساسه والخطيره في على وجه التحديد
اضافه الى ان الاحتلال الاسرا ايضا يمنع
تحرك سيارات الاسعاف من مستشفى الامل
التابع لجمعيه الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني او
الخروج منها او الوصول اليها